I have a confession to make I have an
addiction my addiction is so compulsive
it interferes with everyday life I'm not
as productive as I want to be I often
find it hard to focus and when people
tell me to stop I simply ignore them I'm
addicted to my smartphone really I'm
addicted to distraction and many of us
here are too on a regular day we unlock
our cell phones more than 120 times per
day I decided to run an experiment to
better understand that egg addiction I
of course used my phone to download an
app called moment and began to track my
usage I apparently unlocked my cell
phone more than a hundred and thirty
times per day that is every nine minutes
what is so gripping that I can't resist
on a good day I'm stalking people on
Facebook I haven't seen since middle
school and on a bad day
I'm reading listicles like ten cute
child stars who grew up to be ugly
why do so many of us feel this
compulsive urge to grab our phone
because our phone is like a slot machine
in Vegas we never know what rewards new
tweet you email in the text message that
child start to an ugly awaits us and the
result a hundred and twenty times per
day we lose our focus don't get me wrong
here I love technology because
technology gives us superpowers
superpowers to see my boyfriend in
Berlin every night and to obtain
information about anything in an instant
or to get into his memory about thoughts
and images so sometimes we do use these
superpowers wisely but most often we
don't and the result 120 times per day
we lose our focus there is a tremendous
cost to this at work in our
relationships and with ourselves at work
we could use these superpowers to do
research or to talk to colleagues
instead we're addicted to distraction
look at me on a typical day I'm sitting
on my computer doing actual work and
quickly check my phone see my messages
take a phone call check my emails on my
phone to then immediately hit refresh on
my computer emails again on days like
these I could have as well stared at the
wall for two hours because according to
research my productivity levels are the
same as after pulling an all-nighter at
work I'm present but absent and maybe
you are too
in our relationships we could use our
superpowers to talk to family and
friends all over the world instead we're
often present but absent a friend of
mine recently said lately my fiance and
I come home and grab dinner we're on our
email still and that makes us feel -
we're together but alone
sometimes I even reject his advances
because I quickly want to finish looking
through my Facebook friends
we've gone now from stonewalling to
phone walling as the relationship expert
John Gottman found it's in our
relationship the number one predictor of
an unhappy union is a lack of
responsiveness and attention in her
relationship my friends often finds
herself present but absent and maybe you
do too let's look at ourselves when
we're alone with our thoughts we could
use their superpowers to capture our
thoughts or think about I read
interesting books and articles instead
we're addicted to distraction and what
would you prefer pain or boredom in an
experiment researchers gave participants
a small electric shock that was so
unpleasant that three-quarters of them
were willing to pay not to experience
that Chuck again then research put those
same participants into a room to sit
alone for 15 minutes
subjects were so uncomfortable being
alone with their own thoughts that they
now shock themselves voluntarily
one outlier press that button a hundred
and ninety times in 15 minutes
shocking I know these participants when
they're alone are absent but present but
absent and maybe you are too
so this is the world we live today I
want to sketch out a new world for you a
world where we can finally make use of
these superpowers to live a more present
life at work in our relationships and
with ourselves at work there is a
concept which is called deep work which
makes you focus without distraction on a
single task and the result increase
productivity improve performance and a
sense of true fulfillment that comes
from craftsmanship I tried it when
writing this talk I went and blocked for
our slots I use my phone for research
but ignored all notification emails and
texts the results I felt productive in a
way I had not felt in a very long time I
felt satisfied with my work and with
myself I felt effective and maybe you
would too let's look at our
relationships my mother helped me see in
different world during Christmas her
simple recipe was a cell phone bowl
during meals and family time we had to
put our cell phone into that bowl today
I'm grateful for this world she created
for us Christmas
truly was endless cookie smells laughter
until we all had tears in her eyes and
my grandmother who came gray and looking
much older than I remembered her leaving
looking rejuvenated with red cheeks and
her beautiful smirk during that time I
felt pure joy and maybe you would too
let's look at ourselves after that
memorable Christmas I was sitting on a
plane back to San Francisco I was
sitting in my seat with no emails and
text to distract myself and my mind went
to how excited I felt flying back into
Silicon Valley that this is what
Florence must have felt like in the
Renaissance
and then started wondering about my
constant struggle to juggle my life in
Germany with my life here for more than
a year I've been debating whether to
stay here or to go home after graduation
I started thinking about how grateful I
was for this wonderful family
and I wondered if they knew how much
this time with them meant to me silent
tears started running down my face and
in that moment I decided that despite of
all the opportunities here I will go
home after graduation because it simply
felt right landing in San Francisco that
morning I felt deeply in touch with
myself what about a world where we don't
feel FOMO because of social media but
because we haven't taken the time to
catch up without mental news feed after
that time in that plane I felt clear and
grounded and maybe you were too so how
can you all deal with your own addiction
to distraction what worked for me is to
take present time and space for work to
take time focused time with my family
and to take that time and space to be
alone with my own thoughts today I'm
finally using those superpowers that
technology gives me to live a more
present life at work in my relationships
and with myself I invite you to do the
same take focus time and space where
distraction is not an option where work
is only work where conversation is only
conversation and where self-reflection
enables you to expand more than you
thought was possible in the philosophers
at Katara's words it is the quality of
our consciousness at a given moment that
shapes our future what do you want this
future to be for you